[Music]
we are now learning that the White House
pushed another fake story about The
Border again falsely accusing Texas
officials of blocking border Agents from
helping drowning migrants on Friday and
it made headlines across multiple media
Outlets but Joe Biden's own justice
department debunked the whole thing with
a filing from the incident explaining
that Texas officials weren't even
alerted to the incident until an hour
after after those migrants drowned Fox
News contributor and colonist for the
mess m Joe KRA joins us now Joe the
administration knew this was a lie and
that's why they were ultimately truthful
in a court filing because they knew they
couldn't lie to a court but when it
comes to informing the American people
Joe apparently the Biden White House
thinks it can lie
away this is just unbelievable Todd I
mean our border patrol agents they are
exhausted they are underpaid they are
underappreciated already and on top of
that they have a white house now that is
attacking them again again and again
with let's call them for what they are
Lies We we all remember border patrol
agents being accused of whipping Haitian
migrants remember that and that was
quickly debunk but not before Joe Biden
to kamla Harris to Kar jeanpierre and
more than a few people in the media
accused them of something that never
happened and with this false narrative
the plan was to blame Texas for allowing
migrants to die by Drowning that was not
the case as you just reported overall
more than 1,000 people have died trying
to cross the border Al since Joe Biden
who once urged illegals to Surge the
Border since he took office and we
haven't heard a peep from the White
House about those people now have we
because no one in this White House wants
to talk about the Border because it is a
top issue in this election coming up
right now and Democrats are obviously
most of them anyway are on the wrong
side of this yeah and you just saw all
of those headlines that talked about how
uh the Texas uh agents blocked D DHS
from helping the migrants do you think
that the those stories will now be
corrected they'll be corrected Carly
very quietly it called a stealth edit
right you'll see the headlines suddenly
magically go away or be changed but you
won't see anybody come up in front of a
microphone or write a piece saying we
got this wrong we will do better we will
check first and verify before we go
ahead with this but there was such an
urge to blame Texas and Governor Abbot
for allowing these migrants to die
because they don't want to talk about
the real problem which is all the people
that are dying as a result of fentanyl
coming across this border into this
country and hundreds of terrorists on
the terror watch list coming into this
country uh as a result of this open
border car and this one might not even
be the media's fault because they were
just reporting what DHS was saying but
they didn't check find out in the court
filing that it wasn't true at all and a
lie travels halfway around the world
before the truth catches up as Joe often
reminds us meantime your favorite
climates are John Carrey stop it at a
reporter in Davos
watch what's the C footprint of these
events every single year that you come
here you think it's worth it peasants
pay for your crimes that's a stupid
question is it is it really we're done
we are done now don't grab me why do you
think you're more important your carbon
footprint doesn't matter but everybody
else around the world suggested that
nobody ever suggested that don't make up
stupid questions but Joe carries a very
important person many leatherbound books
he can't be expected to follow the same
rules that he puts out there for the
rest of us and his moral
shaming I like the anchor B reference a
good job B we are done now I mean do you
hear this I mean you can make the
argument that John Carrey has done just
as much as any human being on the planet
to destroy the climate byly flying
private everywhere uh and when he was
asked about why he PES flies private
this about a year ago he said he has to
in order to win this war against climate
change uh no you don't you could very
easily take the middle seat on Swiss Air
to get to places like Davos Mr Cary or
when you're going to Prince Char I'm
sorry King Charles's coronation come on
the hypocrisy is overwhelming here guys
so thank you so much for joining us I'm
Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley
aart and click here to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis